[Music]
breaking news this Tuesday night a
violent assault on a Toronto streetcar a
young woman stabbed multiple times
suspects of female in her 40s the rise
of random acts of violence in Canada's
biggest city as California police deal
with yet another mass shooting
Ukraine's weapon wish the battle tank
set to be deployed to the Battle Zone
core findings the unusual Discovery
Unearthed about the center of our planet
and a triumphant solo track all the way
to the South Pole being alone with the
for sure the the worst part the Canadian
cross-country skier who went
cross-continental
[Music]
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin with some developing and worrying
news in Toronto another person has been
attacked on A Streetcar in the middle of
the day the latest in a string of
violent attacks many of them random in
Canada's largest city police say a woman
in her 20s was stabbed multiple times in
the face and head while riding the
streetcar about 2 p.m in downtown
Toronto she is recovering from serious
but non-life-threatening injuries a
suspect a 40-year-old woman was arrested
shortly after and police say they
recovered a knife investigators do not
believe the suspect and the victim knew
each other if it feels like you've heard
a version of this story before it's
because you have random acts of violence
are on the rise in Toronto the question
is why Mike jourlay has our top story
tonight it was 6 20 p.m three minutes
until Alexander steckel's bus was
scheduled to arrive at her stop she
glanced Dan at her phone unaware she was
a Target I was just standing there and I
felt something kind of just start
hitting my chest and I I looked up I got
hit right in the face before I you know
registered what exactly was hitting me
she looked up to see a car speeding away
with what she believes was a teenager
hanging out the window holding a pellet
or airsoft gun all they said to me was
TTC stecco was wearing her TTC uniform a
few hours earlier two other TTC workers
were riding in a bus in Scarborough when
they were swarmed and beaten Witnesses
say they had asked a group of 10 to 15
Rowdy teenagers to calm down and when
they went to get off apparently they
grabbed the operators and dragged them
off the bus with them so it was really
bad and then when when I got out here
the ambulance was already here and they
were being treated and I one of them had
like a gash on his forehead four 13 year
old boys have since been arrested and
charged with assault random incidents
like these are hard to prevent but
Transit officials say they're far from
isolated nor are they surprised but with
a noticeable increase in people who are
homeless or suffering from mental health
issues using the TTC as a shelter I
can't explain how Transit workers are
feeling at risk and experiencing acts of
violence in the city this has not
happened this rate of this degree and
it's not acceptable but it's not just on
the TTC Toronto has seen some horrific
violence in recent months a 37 year old
man has now been charged with
manslaughter and the death of an 89 year
old woman whom he allegedly pushed to
the ground last week and just before
Christmas 59 year old Ken Lee was beaten
and stabbed to death outside a downtown
shelter eight girls ages 13 to 16 have
been charged to a second-degree murder
Toronto mayor John Tory points to a
growing social and Mental Health crisis
as the cause but he too is unsure of a
solution that would make TTC workers
like Alexander steckel feel safe I mean
at this point I think every day coming
in going home I just have to be thankful
to be alive microwave Global News
Toronto
in California it has happened again
another mass shooting this time seven
people are dead police say an
agricultural worker killed them in
back-to-back shooting sprees at two
mushroom Farms it's only January 24th
and already the toll from mass shootings
in the U.S is shocking there have been
39 mass shootings across the U.S this
year according to gun violence archive
five of them in California at at least
70 people have been killed it is all
hard to comprehend Jackson prosco on the
latest shooting and the lack of Hope
anything will change
the suspected Mass shooter was arrested
outside a sheriff's office while
attempting to turn himself in it
happened after police were called to two
separate scenes in Northern California
where they found eight shooting victims
seven of them dead all of the evidence
we have points to this being the
instance of workplace violence an exact
motive isn't known the gunfire erupted
at a mushroom farm near the coastal city
of Half Moon Bay and later at a second
agricultural facility investigators say
the suspect 66-year-old Chun Li Zhao
worked at the farm there were families
and children living on the property I
have four boys and I cannot imagine what
those kids witnessed today most of the
victims are believed to be migrant
workers making identification and
notification of families more difficult
we've never had one in this County of
this many deaths at one scene or one
time according to police the
semi-automatic handgun used was legally
owned adding to the sense of
hopelessness in a state that has already
experienced five mass shootings this
month in the end there are simply too
many guns in this country
and there has to be a change this is not
an acceptable way for a modern society
to to live its in conduct its Affairs in
the community of Monterey Park a vigil
was held Monday night for the 11 victims
of a shooting at a lunar New Year party
in a dance studio victims like owner
Meng Wai Ma and Mei Mei Nan who were
leaving just as the gunman arrived
actually
got in the car with her partner and she
was backing up and she stopped when she
saw a person and that's when the shooter
went to her side of the window and shot
her the senselessness of both attacks
has left behind a feeling that no place
is safe not when there is so little
political will to stem the tide of gun
violence gripping America
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
a big development in arming Ukraine
there are reports Germany's chancellor
has agreed to send leopard two tanks the
much sought-after battle tank Ukraine
has been pleading for it is a U-turn for
the chancellor who had rejected the idea
of sending lethal weapons wanting
Washington to take the first step in
sending heavy armor and it paves the way
for other countries with german-made
tanks to send them to Redmond Shannon
explains what's changed and what it
means
The german-made Leopard 2 tank is used
by more than a dozen European countries
and by Canada but Berlin needs to give
approval before any other armies can
export their leopards to Ukraine
Poland's prime minister says he has now
formally requested approval
mateosky says Poland and other nations
are already training Ukrainian soldiers
to use the tanks
he accused Berlin of delaying and
dodging on the decision German
Chancellor Olaf Schultz will ultimately
make the call his reluctance likely
influenced by Germany's history the last
time that German tanks were were rolling
across this land was during World War II
and you know some German leaders have
said that they they don't want there to
be the Optics of a once again a German
tank rolling across Ukraine NATO Chief
yens stoltenberg appeared to apply apply
pressure on a visit to Berlin battle
tanks are of course important both to be
able to repel Russian and new offensives
but also for Ukraine to be able to
retake territory later on Monday news
reports indicated Germany will now
export leopard twos and will also
approve others to do the same Canada has
112 of the tanks prime minister Justin
Trudeau was asked about them on Monday
we have nothing to announce today but
we'll continue to look at how best
Canada can help U.S media meanwhile
report that Washington will send some of
its Abrams Tanks to sending those to
Ukraine is going to be a lot more
difficult to do than sending leopard
tanks it could take months to fully
deploy the complex Abrams Tanks any
official announcements will likely
provoke a strong response from the
Kremlin Russia's foreign minister said
Monday that the west and Russia have now
moved Beyond a hybrid War to almost a
real 4. Redmond Shannon double news
London
Ukraine isn't just asking for military
aid but financial help too and ask made
more difficult after more than a dozen
top Ukrainian officials were fired today
some though not all are linked to
allegations of corruption a deputy
defense minister and Deputy prosecutor
general or among those let go no details
were given but there are allegations of
stealing money and paying inflated
prices to feed troops Ukraine is under
intense pressure to prove it can
properly handle billions in Western Aid
it is the biggest shake-up of Ukraine's
wartime leadership since Russia launched
the invasion
in the U.S a retired FBI agent is out on
bail after pleading not guilty to
charges of violating Russian sanctions
and money laundering Charles McGonagall
spent 22 years with the FBI prosecutors
alleged he concealed hundreds of
thousands of dollars he received in
exchange for trying to help a Russian
oligarch get off the sanctions list
McGonagall is also suspected of helping
investigate a Russian rival of that
oligarch and concealing involvement
through shell companies and forged
documents
if you've tried to buy a concert ticket
lately you know what it can cost well
now a U.S Senate committee hearing is
looking into whether the merger of Live
Nation and Ticketmaster has stifled
competition
the only way to restore competition in
this industry is to break up
Ticketmaster and Live Nation
member Ticket Masters website crashed
during a pre-sale event for Taylor
Swift's upcoming tour many have slammed
the company's lack of transparency and
inability to block bought purchases of
tickets today the head of Live Nation
apologized to fans but blamed the Fiasco
on Bots
we were then hit with three times the
amount of Bot traffic that we'd ever
experienced
and for the first time in 400 verified
fan on sales they came after our
verified fan pass password servers as
well
in 2010 Live Nation the biggest concert
venue operator and Ticketmaster the
biggest ticketing system merged experts
say the company controls more than 70
percent of the market for ticketing and
Live Events
Canadians trying to keep up with the
climbing cost of living coming up with
the prime minister in his cabinet have
to say about the year ahead
in Alberta an organization investigating
missing children and unmarked burial
site says it's discovered what it calls
physical and documented evidence of
genocide its preliminary report released
today looked into the blue quills Indian
residential school in Saddle Lake Cree
Nation Morgan black was at today's
announcement Morgan
the report's goal is to provide
community members with an in-depth look
into the operations of the former blue
quill residential school Eric large a
residential school survivor is the lead
investigator and says Catholic Church
records obtained by the at shimowin
opasque view Society showed 212 children
died at the school the group says a more
accurate number is now nearly 400.
records show children died of
tuberculosis contracted from drinking
unpasteurized raw cow's milk from the
livestock kept on site investigators
suggest School administration knew this
would not be best for the Children's
Health as none of the staff contracted
the disease according to records this
was done recklessly at the hands of the
school administrators
who are all now dead
and the department of Indian Affairs did
not impose safety measures for these
children
next year surveying with ground
penetrating radar continues the group
says the results of a final report is
still quite a ways away Morgan black
Global News Saint Paul Alberta
Canadians will find out tomorrow if
there will be another hike in the Bank
of Canada rate the rising cost of living
is front and center as prime minister
Justin Trudeau as cabinet hold a retreat
as turia isri reports there are more
warnings of tough times ahead
the Liberals are admitting the next 12
months may be even bumpier than
predicted I've said very clearly as is
the prime minister 23 is a turbulent of
the Year steering the country through
that turbulence is the focus of the
cabinet retreat in Hamilton we still
have fiscal room to be able to do the
things we need to do but the fiscal room
has tightened the government may have to
make some difficult choices we spoke
very much about the challenges ahead
there is a lot of uncertainty a lot of
volatility in the global economy a new
report from The Business Council of
Canada underlines there is a high risk
that the government will not be able to
deliver the services it promised
Canadians in budget 2022. one of those
promises is a long-awaited health care
funding deal between the federal
government and provinces that economic
risk looms as the Bank of Canada is
expected to announce the eighth interest
rate hike in a row Wednesday we don't
want more interest rates increases that
are absolutely necessary sure to get
back to where we need to go and one of
the reasons is household debt is just so
high the conservatives accuse the
government of adding to the rising cost
of living they accumulated 400 billion
dollars during the pandemic where 40
percent had nothing to do with the
pandemic spending at all so we see
Reckless spending while there are a few
details on how the Liberals plan to
tackle the economic slowdown there were
some specifics on the passport backlog
it came to a head last spring when
Canadians camped out in passport offices
the government says the worst of the
backlog is behind them we are delivering
between 95 and 98 of the time within
those service standards and so Canadians
can have confidence that they should be
able to get their passport on time we
knew that pent-up Demand on travel was
going to happen the borders were closed
people were going to travel so the fact
that a year and a half later they're
doing a bit of a Victory lap on this to
me is a bit disingenuous as the Liberals
work on their strategy for the return to
Parliament one thing political Watchers
will be looking for is campaign style
rhetoric and whether Justin Trudeau May
face off against Pierre paliev earlier
than 2025. Donna
I will watch for that Toria Israel in
Hamilton Ontario thanks center of
attention ahead why the Earth's core
might be changing direction
[Music]
while you may have read the ominous
sounding headlines about the Earth's
core that it has stopped rotating and
maybe reversing Direction it certainly
sounds alarming but apparently it's not
we asked Eric Sorensen to dig deep and
figure out what it means for our
planet's future
beneath the crust below the mantle and
underneath the molten core is the hot
dense solid inner core of our planet and
scientists now believe it rotates and it
even changes Direction every 60 years or
so a planet within the planet there's a
very strong magnetic field down there
it's pressure and gravity and the
magnetic field that all have to balance
we can't drill straight down to the
Earth's center it's around 3000
kilometers through the mantle just to
the outer core but scientists at Peking
University in China found that seismic
waves from earthquakes showed the
Earth's core rotating but also slowing
down and that it stopped just over 10
years ago and appears to be picking up
speed rotating now in the other
direction so what could that mean for
the magnetic forces in and around the
earth there's a powerful but delicate
balance among the magnetic forces of the
Sun the Earth and our planet's
inaccessible interior a magnetic field
protects us from the sun's radiation we
see the interaction of the solar wind
and our magnetic fields in the Northern
Lights the study's authors suggest the
core rotation fits with the 60 to 70
year patterns on the Earth's surface
shifting sea levels Global mean
temperatures potentially tiny changes to
the length of the day an ebb and flow
between the inner earth and the surface
it will fall to the ground we've long
tried to understand the forces beneath
us it will fall in this direction toward
the center of the earth and when
Hollywood heard about it the core of the
Earth has stopped spinning well you can
guess how that turns out microwaves will
literally cook our planet without its
internal convection Mars lost its
magnetic field its heat and went cold
that is not happening here but if we can
predict the subtle shifts down below we
could ultimately prepare for the effects
up above though John vidali says much of
the science remains speculative these
mineral physics people need to explore
what happens at a boundary between the
liquid iron and solid iron it's a whole
range of possibilities of things that
might be happening it will take time and
new modeling to better understand what's
happening what can be said now that
we've discovered that the Earth's core
changes directions at regular intervals
is that apparently that's a good thing
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto
[Music]
a continent next the Canadian skier who
trekked to the South Pole in
run
[Music]
when you return from a trek through
Antarctica just about every place feels
like a five-star hotel that is what
endurance athlete Carolyn Cote
discovered the quebecer is just back in
Canada after setting a new record on a
trek to the South Pole on December 9th a
36 year old Explorer set off solo from
the edge of Antarctica she cross-country
skied 1130 kilometers in 34 days her
goal was to take on one of the most
inaccessible places in the world and she
did that was Mike Armstrong explains the
only part she wasn't prepared for was
the hardest part
these are kind of the official final
steps of Karen Cote's Epic Journey the
silver ball represents the South Pole
and she touched it with slightly
frostbitten fingers I was lucky to just
have a little bit of my hand I don't
feel much on my fingers
now when you've lived through this you
don't complain much about a bit of
frostbite because it could have been
worse could take crossed one of the most
remote and harshest parts of the planet
the temperature averaged in the -30s
with wind if she wasn't in her tent she
had to keep moving to keep her body heat
up Antarctica is a kind of a land of
extreme Cote trained for the trip in
2022 she crossed Greenland with a group
physically it was similar she had to
pull all her supplies on a sled but
mentally being with other people she
says was much easier
Solitude isn't really something you can
train for I felt really alone
I felt that I was not prepared for that
I'm starting the day my location is this
one well Cote pushed on she did deal
with some problems a broken binding on a
ski and a broken solar panel she needed
to charge things like her GPS device
[Music]
but there was a moment that recharged
Cote herself
this was her boyfriend flying over
at this point kote still had 111
kilometers left it gave me a lot of
strength to continue
to do the kilometers and also to do them
fast because I wanted to to be with them
and to celebrate
now back in Montreal Cote says she finds
herself appreciating simple things like
the sounds and smells of the city she
also finds herself talking a lot I'm
with people I'm surrounded with my
family so it's so good to be with her
humans
like I'm from Global News Montreal
it's an accomplishment that is global
national for this Tuesday I'm Donna
Friesen tonight's your candidate is this
bighorn sheep in Okanagan Falls British
Columbia thanks for watching hope to see
you here again tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]